in the last video i hinted that we that
this was leading to a discussion of an
elastic money supply or supply of money
that can change depending on the needs
for the money so before we go there and
i took a little hiatus and told you a
little bit about treasuries because
that's a critical component let's review
what the money supply even is so there
was there were two definitions when we
had originally talked about
kind of an m0 i talked about just the
gold reserves but now we're going to
expand that definition a little bit and
i think you you can tell i've got a lot
of questions about this about eventually
getting off the the um
a gold reserve system and we will get
there and we're kind of already there
but now i'll consider the base money
supply as federal reserve deposits and
notes so in this reality that i just
created
all of the federal reserve deposits have
essentially been turned into notes but
if this bank didn't want all cash it
could have had some of this as just a
checking account with the with the
federal reserve bank so a federal
reserve note and a federal reserve
deposit account is essentially the same
thing a note is just a little bit more
fungible you can hand it to someone and
then they can hand it to someone else
while a checking account or demand
account with the federal reserve bank
you have to kind of do a wire transfer
or write a write a check etc but that is
the base money supply you could call
that base money and that's essentially
the side of the the size of the the
liabilities of the federal reserve in
very broad terms we'll go into detail on
the actual federal reserve's balance
sheet in the near future so in this
example right now our base money supply
is 200
let's call it dollars now let's move
away from gold pieces let's just say a
dollar equals a gold piece for the sake
of our of our instruction right now
so our base money supply and i'll call
that m0
m0 right now is 200
and that's the the cash out there which
is the which are the federal reserve
notes plus the federal reserve demand
deposit so for example this could have
been just a hundred uh like a checking
account
at the reserve bank and then this over
here would have been a checking account
it's dead
but it would still be considered
part of the base money supply because if
this bank who had a checking account
says oh well you know i just want that
in terms of notes then the federal
reserve bank will just issue notes and
cancel out this checking account and it
would turn back into notes so they're
equivalent they're just a different way
of keeping track of it so that's the
base money supply
now a slightly broader definition of the
money supply and we could call this bank
money that's sometimes referred to that
and
the formal definition is
m1
and that's essentially that that notion
that i i went over
i think almost 10 videos ago how much
money do people think they have and
that's the amount of money in demand
deposit accounts
so that in this case
that's this
so all the people in this bank
they think they have a hundred dollars
there
right that's a hundred dollars that they
think that they have that they can write
checks against
and then this bank also has another
hundred dollars and so
they're
the base money supply
no that's not right i don't know sorry
they don't have a hundred why am i
saying a hundred they have
let's see this bank had a hundred
in
gold and it could lend out up to 200 in
or it could put out up to 200 and
checking deposit accounts so it has 200
right that's what i was
right because we talked we talked about
earlier in the last video that we have a
50 reserve ratio which tells us that if
this bank has a hundred dollars in
reserves that it can essentially
manage or it can issue
dollars in demand deposit accounts and
you know we we went over that many times
and how bad it happens and then this
bank can do the same it'll have 200 in
demand deposit accounts
and so the total amount of money that
people think they have either in uh
well in demand deposit accounts in this
in this situation i'm assuming that all
of the cash is sitting in the reserve
banks although we do know that some of
this is going to be sitting around
circulating but let's just say we live
in a world where everyone uses debit
cards all the time and no one uses cash
and i think we're heading to that world
very quickly and and as we'll see soon
that actually increases the money supply
when you do that but anyway i don't want
to go too technical just yet but the m1
which is the total amount of demand
deposit accounts in our universe is 400.
and this this relationship makes a lot
of sense because our reserve
requirements are 50 so we can kind of
assume that banks tend to get as close
to their reserve requirement as they can
because they don't get interest in
reserve on on reserves they they make
interest on the loans that they make
against checking uh uh demand accounts
so if the reserve requirement were 10
and our base money was 200 we would
probably see 2 000 in the m1 supply
so my question
to you is and maybe you want to pause
and think about this is how can the
government or the central bank or the
how can the economy
increase or decrease the money supply
and i guess a first question is well why
would you want to increase or decrease
the money supply well let's say in this
we're we're in this world already and we
only have these two banks and we have a
m1 supply of 400 but let's say the
economy expands we have more goods and
services that are able to produce maybe
we have immigrants come in so we have
more labor maybe we have some innovative
technology maybe
a whole or maybe it's just seasonal
maybe it's the crop planting season so a
lot of farmers need their cash in order
to hire people to plant the crops so
that's another time where you'd want
more money if you don't increase
the money supply at those times when you
have economic expansion or there's just
more demand because of some type of
seasonal fluctuation if you don't
increase the the money then what you're
going to do is money is going to become
more expensive and i'll do a whole video
on that so don't get too confused but
money getting more expensive means that
interest rates will go up and if money
becomes too expensive then some good
projects maybe some farmers who might
have planted seeds wouldn't be able to
and so you would kind of restrict
economic expansion but we'll have a
whole other discussion on
when when does it make sense to expand
or contract money let's just talk now
about how you would actually do it
so there's two ways i just said if this
reserve requirement were 10
then these banks could create more
checking accounts right they could lend
out more money and create more checking
accounts if the reserve requirement were
10
if it was 10 then you would have a
m1 of 2 000
right it would be 10 times this instead
of two times this
there's and and and
and that is considered one of the tools
of the federal reserve bank because we
said in the past that that's that the
federal reserve bank actually sets these
reserve requirements
but the problem with that tool if you
think about it is
what happens if the fed if we made our
reserve requirement 10
right and all of a sudden all of these
banks started lending out a lot more
money and they only had 10 percent the
ratio of reserves to checking accounts
were 10
think about what would happen if we
wanted to raise the reserve requirement
back to 50 percent
then all of the banks they'd only have
10 percent reserves how will they get
back to 50 percent how it would you know
all of these banks would have to either
start
selling assets or or unwinding loans
would be a very messy situation if you
were to lower the reserve requirement
and then wanted to wanted to actually
increase it again you would actually
make a lot of banks
become under capitalized because most
banks just operate right where they need
to so you really don't want to mess
around with this reserve requirement
much
so the question is if you're not going
to change the reserve requirement which
is you know the ratio of the reserves to
checking accounts if you're not going to
mess with that the only other way that
you can actually increase the number of
checking accounts is if somehow you can
increase the reserves if you can somehow
add some actual reserves over here
so my question is how can you do that
well let's just say that well you know
we we've we're hopefully already
reasonably familiar with fractional
reserve banking
so you might have seen it coming
that that also applies to the central
bank so the central bank right now all
of its deposits were directly backed by
gold one to one
but there's nothing to stop this bank
from also doing fractional reserve
lending and actually the central bank
has no
reserve requirement and that's because
to some degree it can always provide the
liquidity because it's its notes are
obligations of the government so it can
always tax more people to back up
to back up its loans so what essentially
the federal reserve can do is
and this is this is the printing press
of the base money supply that people
talk about but there's two printing
presses there's a base money printing
press and then there's the leverage
printing press so this increases well
i'll do a whole video on that another i
don't want to get too technical because
i realize i'm running out of time
so what the federal reserve could do in
this situation
is it can
print some notes
so let's say it prints 100 of notes
right and those are just it literally
just prints those dollars you know it
pays the treasury to print it form but
it creates these notes
and then of course offsetting that is a
liability
right notes outstanding
a hundred liability and then what it
does is it takes these hundred
dollars i mean these are literally
dollar bills although it could be you
know uh some type of demand account or
whatever but it takes these hundred
dollar bills that it printed and it's
just is the offsetting liability and
then it can buy treasury securities so
what happens if it takes these hundred
dollar bills and buys treasuries
so and the treasuries don't have to be
issued by the government anymore because
whenever the government does issue
treasuries it's bought by just a bunch
of people in the world it does it's not
you know there's always a bunch of
treasury sitting out there as long as
the treasury has some debt so i was
holding the treasuries and now let's say
that this is the central bank
i was
i was holding some some of these
government ious right that i had bought
from the government
and the treasury department
uh sorry the federal reserve they have
this hundred dollars
they have a hundred dollars let me draw
that in green
they have a hundred dollars so they just
buy the treasury from me
and you know maybe i don't want to sell
it at the current price so they have to
pay me a little bit more than the
current price in order for me to part
with it and i'll do a whole other video
on how what that means and how that
changes the yield curve and all of that
but just i just want to get you that
base notion that the treasury
essentially creates a notes outstanding
liability and has an offsetting dollars
of dollar bills that it just created or
prints
and then it can use those hundred dollar
bills to buy
treasuries or government ious in the
open market and now what happens here
well these hundred dollar bills these
are now treasuries
let me change that to treasuries
and my question to you is what am i i
was holding a treasury it was sitting in
my mattress what am i now going now i
don't have a treasury i have a hundred
dollars what am i going to do with that
hundred dollars well i'm going to
deposit it in the bank
i'm going to deposit it in the bank so
this is me depositing my hundred dollars
let me maybe i deposit it up here
but and i i have my checking account
grows a little bit but what's the net
effect now all of a sudden the banking
system the the national banking system
has more currency more dollar reserves
that apply to its reserve ratio so now
it got my hundred dollar deposit now it
can also do another hundred dollars of
lending so i would have essentially
increased the base so now the m0 goes
from 200 to 300
right because i have 300 notes
outstanding and on my m1 i took that
hundred dollar bill that the treasury
gave me deposited in a bank account now
the i have a bank account that says 100
and then the because of a 50 reserve
requirement the bank can issue another
loan i know it's getting messy
400.
so essentially our m1 is now 600 so just
like that just by
printing money and issuing treasuries
the government was able to increase the
m or the the treasure the sorry the
central bank was able to increase the m1
by 200 dollars i'll do more videos on
this i don't want to confuse you too
much see you soon